Hello to you, I'm Gav
I'm Dan.
We're the slow mo guys.
As you can see I'm wearing
my dangerous outfit again.
I've got everything this time.
When Dan's wearing the blue suit,
you know its gonna be a good one.
Stuff's gonna go down.
I'm very fascinated by aerosol cans,
and the fact that there's
liquid in there pressurized
and as soon as the pressure's released,
it just vaporizes.
We did it with the deodorant
can along time ago,
and I wanna do it with paint.
Yeah we've got lots of
different colors of spray paint
behind me there as you can see.
So I'm gonna take an ax
and a sledge hammer to them
and see if we can get
some different effects .
Yeah, we're basically
gonna some spray paint art
without once using the
nozzle of the spray paint.
How can we get it out of there
without using the correct method
of getting it out of there?
Feel free to send us your methods
of getting spray paint out
of a can without spraying it.
But don't do it with an ax
or a sledge hammer because its dangerous.
But be safe.
Send in your answers on a post card.
So I think we'll start--
we'll start with some green.
And before we move on to
ax and sledge
let's do a BB gun.
Oh yeah.
I can't believe that it didn't go anywhere
and only painted the background.
Like we couldn't have
done that if we tried.
All right, let's try again with red
and see if you can glance it
and maybe get it to spin through the air.
Hit it on the side and just--
Whoa!
That's what we want.
Oh man,
the grass is now blue.
So the glance was definitely different.
spotted completely.
We didn't put a tap down
on the garden obviously.
No.
The green one, I thought just--
and I was like, "Oh, okay.
"Well, that--
"Whatever."
But the blue, we hit on the side,
it just went absolutely mental.
We should've done that with the green
because then it would've
just painted the grass green.
Ah,
perhaps we could do green
now and just repaint it.
Yeah, as you can see,
the entrance wound
is at the side in this angle.
And that's why this time it spun around.
Where's the exit?
It stays in there.
Oh really?
Yeah, it doesn't make it out.
Well they come with like a little shaky
ball bearing in there, don't they?
Well now it's got an extra one.
there's two now.
That's coming along nicely,
it's a bit of a--
Is it called a--
a wibble?
What's the thing in the middle called?
In the middle of a spray can?
A woggle?
I thought that's what you
wear when you're tying cubs.
In cubs?
Yeah,
like cub scouts.
Woggle, wiffle, woggle?
Pretty sure, a boggle.
An og goggler?
I think it might be an og goggler, yeah.
A fedge gondola.
You get them in beer as well.
Fibbler?
Foggler.
Foggler?
Fob woggler.
How am I ever gonna sell this place?
I have to wait for it to
grow out and mow over it.
It was my plan all along.
All right, I think that's some good work
on the distance once.
Yeah absolutely.
You wanna get up close and
personal, maybe the ax?
I think I'm ready, I've
got my kit and equipment.
Oh my goodness!
Good Lord!
I was not expecting that.
I was not expecting--
I know I was just about
to ax a can and all,
but--
look at me.
Whoa!
Bloody!
Okay, Sledge Ronnie.
Ready?
Yeah.
You want a sledge then?
That was wicked!
I think we've got enough sledge.
How about
a length-ways ax cut?
So, you want me to hit it
like this down the length
of the can like that?
Yeah.
I mean honestly, this
is just experimentation,
I've got no idea if it'll
look different or anything.
Bloody like that, you know,
there's like an area there
where it's like
so layered.
Yeah, the background's
getting really soggy.
Is it?
Yeah.
We'll have to dry it out.
Whoa!
Remember that really nice layer right now
I was just talking about?
Yeah.
All gone.
Bloody all under the green .
I think our painting is almost complete.
We just need sort of
maybe a multicolor.
Yeah okay, well like four fume in one.
Why do you sound so terrible?
I just got a cold.
Okay,
grand finale.
I just went
poof!
And I just went--
I blasted back.
Like sprayed on my feet,
it's sparkly.
Oh wow,
it's over some of that.
One on your face too.
I know.
And I was gonna say, "And my face."
every time it's my ankles,
my hands and my face.
Nothing else gets hit at all.
Although, we got some
well nice new patterns on this.
Oh, sick!
Look at these.
This is uncopyable, this.
It's copyable
but it would take you some
sweet reference and time.
Let's make the final
touches to this painting.
Here we go.
We've ruined your back garden, basically.
I mean it was dangerous and messy
but worth it.
It was worth it, your voice just shot.
Like most of our work, it's
smeary and not symmetrical.
I got high.
You got high on some paint fumes?
Yeah.
Nice video.
Look at this, look.
There's bits of label, wood, grass,
this is shoddy.
We went through a lot of paint cans.
We did.
I think this ones knacking,
we should probably hold on to this.
This one, I think, could
be a nice piece of art.
So we'll slop it on eBay
for a week
and donate the proceeds
to Extra Life charity.
If you feel interested in having this--
well, this absolute masterpiece.
Dang Rishi Fund?
We're not gonna donate to Dang Rishi fund,
that is off limits.
It's a terrible charity.
Hopefully you enjoyed that vid.
Feel free to subscribe to the channel,
the second channel.
Twitter and that,
buy a shirt, bid on some art,
there's a lot for you to
think about right now.
Or just turn it off.
And go elsewhere, go by your day.
Don't do that.
Eh, freedom.
Freedom of the internet.
See you next time.